Marjorie Taylor green of Jewish space
laser Peach Tree Bill Gates wants you to
eat his fake meat that grows in a peach
tree dish gazpacho police but now we
have Nancy Pelosi's gazpacho police Fame
now says she has the evidence to impeach
Joe Biden Joe Biden will be impeached
hint she doesn't have the evidence to
impeach Joe Biden but it doesn't matter
we now are dealing with an assertion
from an alleged whistleblower about
alleged bribery that Joe Biden is
allegedly involved in now if any of that
is true I as someone who is not a
hypocrite would say investigate
if there's evidence of criminality
charge Joe Biden if he's convicted
sentence Joe Biden appropriately and
fairly because I don't play favorites
with the law if it's Trump or Biden or
hunter or Hillary or Obama whoever it is